Cái đó các giảm bố khi chế lực mới nguyên niêu stong giống nghĩ và ngà dự kiến như được
lực phần ngày 15.2, làm gia tăng quan gại thì một khoảng trống kìm xuất hạc nhân
đối với anh ninh còn cầu. Nếu không có thuật thẩy thay thì đây sẽ là là đủ tiên
sau nhiều thậm niên, 2 cường có sử nữ phần lớn có đồ đại hạc nhìn thế giới
không bị giang buộc bởi bất kì về bất sọc viên nào.
Được kiến năm 2020, niêu stong giữa hạm 1 bê nếu mới mừng mình nít nắp trinh
đồ đại hạc nhân trên nửa đồng thời có kìa thình sáng nhầm xe dựng lòng tiên.
Tuy nhiên, có họ đồng thình xác đã bị điên trị kìm năm 2020.
Phân ngôn viên điện khem li điểm triê pha scope cho biết, kìa từ đó ngà vẫn tôn thu hợp hợp
bởi vì giả hạm thiên 1 năm, còn bị vẫn chưa có tí niệu phần hồi.
Trong những phần nguyên nhất, ngà triệu biết đã chuẩn bị chức bản hậu niêu stong,
bà sãi sàng cho một thị dời không dàng mộp về hạc nhân.
Châu khi đó, niệp bày tò ló ngại với tốt độ mở giọc lực lượng hạp nhân của Trung Quốc,
và trời sàng không khổ kiểm soát hiện nay chưa và nặng đầy đủ tu tế mới.
Về phần mình Trung Quốc phản định không tham gia thức của đam pham pham pham pham bên,
biển giảm dự chinh lịch lớn về quy mò khó vũ khí,
giời phần tích kính báo Việt News.chm dẫn có thể làm giá tăng nguyên tơ trị đu vũ trang,
và gế bất đồn an đing tòn cầu.